I think people just make this jump, though, when I give those talks, especially the Recon one,
they're like, ah, Recon's gonna find me bugs. And that is not, that's where it falls apart,
right? Like, Recon doesn't really find you bugs. Preach, Jason. Yeah, like, so I use Recon,
and I give all these esoteric methods of Recon, and I make a whole talk about Recon
to find more apps to hack.
Okay, so Jason, let me start us off with this, okay? I think you're one of the first role models
that I had in the bug bounty world, to be perfectly honest, man. Like, I remember, I don't know why
this memory is so, like, strong for me, but I remember sitting on the floor in my room when I
just moved, and I was like, dude, I think I gotta do this bug bounty thing. And just, you know,
searching and finding your video, your, I think it was one of your level up videos with bug crowd,
and, you know, the bug bounty hunting methodology, you know, videos, and I just sat there, and I just
watched it, like, four times on repeat. And I was like, you know what, I'm gonna have mastery of
every single one of these things. So, I don't know, it's just, it's just one of the, one of my first
memories that I had with it. So, I'm really, I'm really grateful to have you on the show.
Thanks, man. It means a lot to me. It really does. Thank you.
Yeah, and I'll echo a similar thought as well. I mean, you were definitely one of the first,
like, major resources that I looked up in bug bounty for, like, how to start hacking, and, like,
what to even, like, do when it comes to, like, hacking, and how to find bugs, and all that kind
of stuff. That's, that's so awesome. You know, when you, when you get older in the game,
you know, younger guys like yourself who come along, who are just, like, so much better than me,
honestly, saying that they took inspiration from you feels, it feels great. So, I'm glad I'm doing
something positive. So, yeah, yeah, for sure, man. And, and, yeah, absolutely inspiration. And,
and so, I had a couple things here. I want to give you an opportunity to do your own introduction.
Um, but I also wanted to give a little introduction myself. First time ever doing an introduction on a
podcast like this. So, Jason Haddix, if you guys haven't heard of him, you're doing something wrong.
Um, OG Hacker, really, really shares some amazing content, um, for, for bug bounty hunting methodology,
in, in particular. Um, I guess when I think of you, Jason, a couple things pop to pop into my mind.
First of all, you know, you have street cred in the industry, right? Like you, you were number one
hacker on bug crowd for a while. Like you're in the weeds doing the hacking and even to this day,
still doing the hacking. But now you've, you've pivoted a little bit into your CISO now, right?
Yeah. Correct. Yeah. So this is kind of where, you know, this is kind of where I kind of see,
I see two paths in the future for Justin, right? I can go the, I can go to sort of the,
the Franz Rosen path, the, the entrepreneur, like he's out there, he has like three companies
or something like that. Or I can go the Jason Haddix path of like, all right, I want to be C-suite.
I want to be, you know, helping manage a cybersecurity program from a top level. So you've,
you've pulled that off. And the other things that just kind of come to my head, we've already
talked about what kind of a great educator you are, but also another, another role model piece
for me is just a part of your online persona and something that you are very public about
is, you know, being a great dad. And, uh, I, I think it's really refreshing to see that sort
of prioritization in industry. And even when we were scheduling this podcast, you were like, Hey,
you know, yeah, I can come on, but actually I've got to spend some time with my family.
Um, and I've got that blocked off from here to here. And I was just like, man,
so yeah, we thought we couldn't like him anymore. He's a family man too. Yeah. Yeah. It's,
it's great, man. So yeah, thanks so much. Yeah. With that, you know, why don't you give us a
little bit of an, uh, a self intro yourself and, uh, yeah, absolutely. Um, yeah. So, uh, like I said,
Jason Haddix, I've, um, I've been in the offensive security scene, I would say for probably about 15
years. Um, so, uh, really I got started, you know, shortly after the loft era where we, we started to
see more consultancies doing penetration testing as kind of the main thing and DAS scanners were just
starting to come out and stuff like that. And so, um, you know, really I, I was in, uh, college, I did a
dark net diary story of kind of like my story, but, um, you know, I was in college and I was mostly on
the underground scene back when shadow crew was a thing, it was a big underlying underground forum
before the dark web was really the dark web. And, um, yeah, I was learning hacking there. I was
originally just making fake credit cards, uh, or not fake credit cards, sorry, fake IDs, um,
fake IDs. Yeah. I was like, no, no, no, sorry. Uh, fake IDs. Sorry. Free coffee. But, um, yeah,
I was making, I was making fake IDs and, uh, just for me and my friends. And then part of that
forum ecosystem is like the people who use the fake IDs for the carding. And the other part of
that forum, you know, underground kind of lifestyle is the people who provide the dumps, which is the
credit card numbers. And those are the hackers really. And so, um, you know, I was starting to
get some exposure to hacking there. And then I took an elective at my college, which was a junior
college and it was called ethical hacking and network defense. It was just one class. Wow. Yeah.
And it was old already by the time it was out, it was like super old. They were talking about like
back orifice and stuff like that. But, uh, I was talking to my teacher and he's like, yeah, you can
make money, you know, being a professional like hacker. And I was like, that is exactly what I want
to do. Like, that sounds amazing. Um, and so I just kind of threw myself into it from like my early
twenties, um, into everything. So back there, and it was a lot of net pen service exploitation with like
generic, you know, you know, buffer overflows. Web was really starting to take off like SQL injection
and rainforest puppy were, um, you know, we're just starting to take off. Yes. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Yeah. Uh, anyway, so I did that. I, um, I went on to a small consultancy, uh, and then eventually
after that, I landed at HP working with a really great team at HP. Um, and we built a small little
startup inside of HP called shadow labs, um, which was a testing team. And, uh, it was one of the best
experiences of my life, worked with some great people. And, um, we did a lot of, uh, cutting edge
mobile research back when, before iOS pivoted to Swift, we were, you know, back on the objective C
train and, um, tons of mobile research there. I built a binary analysis tool there, did a whole bunch
of web penetration testing, uh, and then left, uh, because bug crowd was around. And so, uh, I knew
Casey from the industry and he was like, uh, he was like, yo, I'm starting this thing. I'm really only
doing it via email right now. There was no platform. Literally, they just emailed you a program and a
scope and they were like, and I think they used back then, they used like survey monkey or something
to run the whole thing. It was crazy. And so he's like, I'm literally just going to give me, give me some
context on this. What year was this? Oh, geez. I know. I hate asking that question to people because
if somebody asked me that. Let me go back. Hold on. So, so you guys asked me to bring some, uh, you asked
me to bring some, uh, bugs. Let me just go back to my submission timeline. Yeah, yeah, for sure. Do
that. And I just, I'm interested because you said you knew Casey from the industry and then, you know,
if you're, it's really cool that you were like one of these, one of these, you know, first people
interacting with bug crowd, um, as they were starting to, I mean, it really seems like they were
almost in like minimum viable product phase back then. Oh yeah. Yeah, for sure. They were, I mean,
uh, it was Jay Cran and Casey and like, I think five other people had just moved into an office in
San Francisco, all crammed in like a garage office somewhere. Um, and, uh, yeah. And so they were
managing everything via survey monkey. So your, your bug submissions would be to like a survey monkey
URL and then they'd be handled like support tickets for like, you know, a support place. Um, and then they
would just send you an email and they're like, and this is back in the day of time boxed. Um,
so like, you know, it would be like 48 hours. This program is going to be open. Um, 48 hours
programs can be open. Here's the scope, uh, and, uh, first come first serve until so much money was
exhausted. And that was the old format, um, of, of most of the bounties. And so like,
we still, we still see that a little bit. It's a, I think they mostly do that when they're onboarding,
you know, new programs and stuff like that nowadays too. Yeah. Yeah. The, the exhausting,
the money thing doesn't happen as much nowadays, but sometimes it still does on the private ones. So,
um, Jesus Christ. Okay. So this is more than 10 years ago. Cause I'm having to scroll all the way
down. Yeah. It's crazy. Yeah. Uh, let's see here. What was the first one? Um, I mean,
you could probably count on it on two hands, maybe one, even one hand. Yeah. The number of people that
have bugs going back 10 years. Yeah. Hold on. That's crazy. Yeah. So, um, yeah. So I started
doing bug crowd during the nights when I was in pen testing during the day for HP. Sure. And, um,
really the guy who really made me obsessive with it was Bitquark. Um, he's another really great hacker
in the scene. And, uh, so we were, we were neck and neck in the leaderboard for, for like a year,
basically up and down and up and down. Um, and honestly, he's a, you know, he's, he's one of the
best hackers in the world. If you ever meet this guy, Bitquark is, uh, you know, a great guy. I've met
him at DEF CON and, um, he likes to keep his privacy, but he was very, very technical. And, um,
but we battled for like a year on the leaderboard when bug crowd, you know, even first launched
you. Right. Yeah. So exactly 10 years. The first one I participated in, uh, was 10 years
ago. My first bounty, you guys want to know what my first bounty was? Hit us, hit us with
it. You guys are going to laugh. All right. $100 and five points for missing HTTP cooking
flag. I know, I know, right? I know, dude. I know, you know,
it's, uh, my first, uh, my first big one was a web application firewall bypass. Um,
so that one was, I think it was a WordPress WAF that they had implemented and you could
add, uh, a header that basically said like, you know, gave it like a address of one 27,
zero zero one and it wouldn't apply checks to you anymore.
Nice. Um, that's, that's, that's crazy though. Cause you know, I guess at that time, you
know, the standards were kind of still being established for what exactly bug Donnie was
morphing into. And now, you know, in this modern day area, you know, era, we're kind of in
this place of like POC or GTFO. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Have very exploitable bugs. But in the
beginning, you know, it was, it was the closest thing to it was a pen test. Exactly. And, and so,
you know, why wouldn't you report? I mean, I was reporting, I mean, that's something I learned
right away. Right. Like, so the bug bounty, it morphed pretty quickly to like, Hey, the stuff
you're going to report, uh, as information on a pen test should really not be reported to
a bug bounty. Like, it's just, it's not something they really care about or they've seen it before
or whatever. But in back in the day, honestly, like even some people were not talking about
like cookie security, right. Or like, or header security. And so like, this was pretty cutting
edge 10 years ago. So people were like, Oh yeah, I can mitigate, you know, certain portions
of sea surf and cross that request forgery. If I just set this cookie and I was like,
well, why don't I report it? Right. If they want to take it, they'll take it. And if they don't want
to take it, they won't. And so some, like I, I continue to do this for like months and some
people did and some people were like, nah, that's cool. And like, you know, like a lot of my bigger
bugs, you know, in the years following were obviously like, you know, like sequel injection
and stuff like that. If I'm scrolling up here, but, um, yeah, I don't know why, but like,
I just, I cannot find sequel injection. Like I've found, you know, I've been doing this full
time for three years. I've been hacking, you know, six years, you know, so really experienced over
here, but, um, uh, you know, I found maybe like, it's just one of those bugs that always gets, gets
past me. I've found like five or six equal injections in my home. So that's like one a year
for my whole career. And I just, I don't know. I just, maybe it's the targets. Maybe it's my testing
methodology, but whenever anybody says, yeah, you know what? My, one of my main bugs is sequel
injections. I'm like, really? Like, are you sure? Like, Oh yeah. Yeah. It's, it was more prevalent
back then for sure. I feel like sequel injections almost solved, I think at this point. And yeah,
you know, I think, I think there's also this thing that people don't talk about is like,
um, there are generations of hackers now, right? So there are people who've grown up with cloud first
and, um, and newer languages and frameworks that, you know, these bugs are all but extinct in, in this
new stuff. But when you get on a program, that's legacy, man, I wrecked those programs. Cause I grew
up in those technologies, right? Like Java and stuff like that. And like, and they still have sequel
injection all over the place because like no one's audited that code in 8 million years, especially if
it's closed source. So, um, yeah, I mean, it, it is funny because like, uh, you know, like when I get
on like an, like when I know an old, a program is, um, is based on like an older technology or
framework or, or is a legacy company, um, which, you know, many of the bigger companies in the world
are, you know, still carrying legacy technology. Um, you know, you still find some of that kind of stuff.
So yeah, I know who to ping now when I get a cool private legacy program. Yeah. So, um, yeah,
so I worked at bug crowd, uh, battled it out for leaderboard spot. Number one, I think that was in
2016 and 2017 and maybe a little bit of 2018 and then bug bounty blew up. Um, and I went to work for
bug crowd cause I want to be involved in it. And, uh, I mean, did you just hit Casey up and be like,
Hey man, I'm loving this. Or did they hit you up or how did that go?
Um, so I met him at DEFCON. They flew me out, uh, for being the number one researcher. And I got to
meet like Franz and Onshimin and some other really cool people for the first time, Bitcork. And, um,
and I was like, yeah, I want to be involved in this. I told Casey, I'm like, how, you know,
like how can I work for you guys? And they needed a head of the triage team, basically a head of
operations. And, um, I was like, yeah, I could do that. I mean, it wasn't, it wasn't too
unsimilar from managing a pen test team, honestly. Um, and I wanted to build like a
world-class pen, you know, triage team. They, they say that to you, right? They say,
Hey, we need a head of triage. Yeah. What's going through your head at this point? Because
like, so you're currently employed or no, or yeah. Yeah. I'm employed. You are. Okay.
So you're doing bug bounty on the side, you know, I don't know, you know, what kind of money you were
making at the time, but when I was employed and I was doing bug bounty, there was a point where my bug bounty
income surpassed my, my main income. Right. And that was like, okay, I need to like,
I need to go full-time bug bounty because there's no reason for me to be doing this. Um,
but if I were to have hacker one or bug crowd or, you know, any of these programs, uh, or these
platforms reach out to me and say, Hey, Justin, we want you to come do X, Y, Z, but you can't hack.
Yeah. That was, that was part of the agreement. Yeah. Yeah. So they, um, basically the rule,
I mean, there wasn't hard and soft policies back then, but, um, the rule, once I came on,
I was the first kind of tester that they had, you know, running an operations team. And so any program
I had access to, I wasn't allowed to hack on, um, which was a lot of programs because, uh, we hadn't
built out a just in time access system. Like, you know, back then it was like, you know, you would get
invites and it was like a crap I have, you know, like, because I'm in a marketing role and an
operations role and like, I, you know, I'm talking to these customers all the time. So I guess that
means I can't hack on these things. So it really did stop my hunting for like a year and a half
until they came out, you know, with, um, with some stuff and some new policies. And then I could get
back to hacking. But, um, you know, like that's a lot of things. A lot of people don't talk about,
honestly, is that, you know, people like us who have full-time security jobs and are bug bounty hunting
also take moonlight work and my moonlight pen test work was able to keep me through, you know,
just doing side pen tests for people, um, was able to replace that bounty kind of money.
That makes sense. I mean, I guess maybe I should, I should hit Casey up and ask him this question,
but I feel like it's a little bit of a, I feel like it's a little bit of an odd move as a startup
to take your top hacker and then employ him and then say, now you can't hack. Like,
I don't know. I feel like that's a little bit of a weird move because at that point they still need
to sell their product. And for, for them, you know, you are one of the main selling point. I mean, you
pretty much like, I would imagine at that point, you know, some high percentage of the, the bugs being
submitted are you. And so they're, they kind of cut that, that, you know, contributions to the platform
out when they employed you. And obviously they gained a lot of other benefits and, and stuff like
that, but I don't know. What do you think about that decision? Did that slow them down at all or?
My final position at HP before I left was director of penetration testing at HP, um, which was a giant
role and carried with it a lot of clout because I think the only director of penetration testing in the
world was Dan Kaminsky at that time at IO active. Wow. Um, and so, uh, OG shit. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm fan boy in a little bit here. Um, and so I, they definitely gained more than they lost. Right.
Yeah. Uh, because I am really good at, you know, basically marketing and sales and all this other
stuff that, you know, I think for many, many years, you know, it was like, oh, Jason Haddix is involved
in bug crowd. Let's go check them out and see what they're about. And I know the triage team,
he's leading that. So it must be really good. And, um, so I think it far outweighed, you know,
my, my bug hunting contributions. So, okay. So you had enough of a clout in the community at that
point to, to be able to transition, you know, over to bug crowd and then, you know, use that position
to help bug crowd sort of sell the product and get in it very, that makes sense. That makes sense.
Yeah. All right, Casey. All right. I didn't mean to call you out, Casey. Like, you know, I knew,
you knew what you were doing, but Casey, Casey's actually so brilliant. I mean, um, yeah, he's not,
he's not front and center and a lot of stuff, but he's one of the smartest entrepreneurs I've ever met,
honestly. Uh, and I would work, I would work with him again in a second at a, at a new, at a new venture,
if you know, if anything ever happened, but, um, Casey's my bro. So anyway, so I worked at bug crowd
for five years. Um, and then, uh, you know, I went through a number of roles. I went through the
operations, um, director of operations, and then to head of trust and security, which is a hybrid security
role. Um, and then our sales engineering leader left. Um, and then I stepped into basically sales
engineering, um, which I stayed in for a year and a half cause I was really good at it. Um,
and then I left that role to go to researcher success. And I was head of, uh, researcher enablement,
basically, which was to basically grow kind of, uh, the number of good hackers on bug crowd, uh, and to
compete with kind of the marketing spend that hacker one spends on like really pushing the hacker
faces out there. Um, we wanted to, you know, do the same stuff. And so created the ambassador program,
created the free education, helped create level up, um, you know, pushed our conference and marketing
kind of agenda, uh, our open source tools, all of that. I was, I was doing all of that.
That's kind of the position I remember you from, you know, that's my, that's my intro.
Yeah. Yeah. Was at that point. Yeah. Yeah. So, so what point did you start,
like, had you already started working on the bug bunny, like hackers, like methodology at that point,
or? Yeah. I, um, so I did the first version of what I would call, uh, the bug hunters methodology talk,
um, at DEFCON 16, I think. And, um, and it was back then it was called how to shot web.
Um, and it was, yeah. And so it was, it was the, it was in DEFCON 101 tracks and, um, it was, you know,
it was, it was not as refined as it is now, but, um, yeah, I mean, back then a lot of people weren't
really talking about recon and even really in depth kind of web things that we take for granted now.
Right. So like, um, you know, kind of new school frameworks, probably got paint payloads,
you know, file upload vulnerabilities are still everywhere, you know? And so I just started talking
to friends and parsing like every blog I could and just put it into this presentation that I was like,
Hey, if you're a web tester, you know, maybe you'll find something useful in this giant dump of
information and, and, uh, people really, really, really responded to it. I got hundreds of messages
and like, that's the best web presentation I've seen all year. And I was like, all right, cool. So
maybe I'll just do this every year and I'll talk about bug classes and tools that save time for pen
testers and bug hunters. And, and that's kind of what the talk morphed into. And, um, yeah, so that's
when I started that talk. That's awesome, man. Yeah. That's just such a legendary piece. And when you,
when you said how to shot web, I just got flooded by nostalgia. I definitely went back and looked into
that. And so that was really cool. Yeah. Um, so I left, I left bug crowd went onto Ubisoft as the CISO,
um, wanted to try my hand at like the big org CISO role. And that was, uh, that was a lot of fun.
I did a lot of really great work there with some tremendous people, um, you know, lived through,
you know, working three years at Ubisoft was like working 10 years at any other company.
Um, because it was giants. It was 22,000 people. Um, the, the, uh, the thing is that,
uh, we were one central security group managing all of those people who are primarily devs.
It was still hybrid legacy. Um, so a lot of security issues to take care of a lot of security programs to run.
And then honestly, the hardest thing about the gaming industry, um, is that each game
in and of itself is like a product team. And so if you can imagine having one company with 60 products
and you have to secure them, it is insane. Um, and you learn so much because they're not standardized.
They're each their own tech stack infrastructure. Some people were building their own stuff. Some people
are using cloud and it's like, okay, so you're a group of, you know, 50 to a hundred people,
but you have 60 products to secure. It's a, it's amazingly drinking from the fire hose. Yeah. It's crazy.
Wow. Yeah. That, that I couldn't even imagine, you know, that level of dealing with that many employees.
Yeah. It was nuts. Uh, and I, so I did that. I enjoyed it. Um, but then I left and now I am at a
place called butto bot. Okay. Um, tell me a bit about that. And actually that that's headquartered in,
in Virginia. Yes, it is. Yeah. All right. Where, where are you at currently? I'm in Colorado.
Okay. Oh yeah. Yeah. That's right. That's right. You're in Colorado. Yeah.
Dude, you know, Virginia welcomes you, man. Okay. All right. I'm trying to sell Joel on moving over
here in the works. It's a, it's a nice place. I like it a lot. So, um, yeah, I mean, uh, we moved
to Colorado just because, uh, we need a bigger space for the fam, right? We wanted every kid to have a
room and I wanted a basement that was kind of sound isolated to do stuff like this. So, um, that's,
we chose Colorado, but, uh, but yeah, so butto bot, like I said, I lived through my moonlighting
sometimes, um, and, you know, made extra income and I always moonlighted with this company called
butto bot with a friend of mine, Luke who built this company. Oh, nice. And, um, he's been, you know,
he's been doing this for 10 years, but on the DOD side. So DOD pen test, DOD security contracting,
um, and has a really great relationship with a lot of the three letter agencies. And so I would come on
and do these tests for him and then, you know, off board and, um, we always really work together.
And so, uh, this last year he was like, Hey, do you want to come and really push this thing into the,
you know, the regular enterprises of the world, uh, and build out, you know, like, uh, kind of a,
a little bit of, um, a regression, but also like a way forward, um, in security testing. I was like,
yeah, so I'll, I'll come and lead it. So, um, so I am now the CISO of butto bot, but really I'm,
I'm, I'm doing everything. It's, you know, we're about on this side, we're about, you know,
15 to 20 people. Um, and so we're doing full scope adversary emulation. So one thing I learned
at, uh, at Ubisoft, uh, with the lapsus incident that happened and, and just like living in that world,
talking to CISO friends is that there's a giant disconnect between bug bounty and penetration
testing. It actually causes an incident at, um, at a company. And so adversaries like,
yeah, they do take advantage of application infrastructure bugs. Uh, but more often than
not, they're using phishing, they're using configuration, like, you know, bugs. Um,
Uh, they're using bugs that you haven't turned off. Right. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Um, but the,
actually one of the biggest ones is, is just like, they're not even doing the work themselves all
the time. Right. So like they're going to dark net markets and picking up credentials and doing
credential stuffing and using them in novel ways. And, um, the more and more I talked to CISOs last year,
I was like, yeah, I mean, there's a couple of red team companies that do full scope stuff like this,
but there's not many. And I really, I really think that, you know, from seeing everything at my time
at Ubisoft, that someone needs to offer a full scope service. So what we do at Budobot is we do
like a, a year long, we call it, um, continuous adversary emulation. It's a year long service.
Um, so we scope the project, do recon upfront, um, for the external. Um, we do, so year of testing,
um, basically for you. And that's like, I mean, is that the go-to product or is that the minimum
product or like? That's like, that's the premium product. Yeah. Okay. That's the premium product.
Okay. That's what you're trying to, you know, you may, you may, you know, people say, Hey,
I can't handle, you know, a year of testing budget wise, then kind of scale it off. But that's,
that's the, that's the product that you're trying to get out there. Yeah. I mean the,
the general narrative is basically that, you know, like hackers don't really take a break. Right.
And it's why a lot of people pivot to bug bounty. Right. Um, you know, a lot of the times, but, um,
so we're offering advanced social engineering with it. We're going to the dark web. We're pulling
creds off of things like Genesis market and stuff like that. So we bake in a whole bunch of threat
intelligence. We also do attack surface management. So I basically took everything that I thought,
you know, what are real adversaries doing these days to get in from the external and how can I
turn that into a service? And then I also took kind of my 15 years of internal penetration testing
and red teaming. And so we do, we do about eight externals over the course of 12 months and two
internals. And we turn it into the service called, um, continuous adversary emulation. And then we bake
in some stuff at the end too, to do atomic red team testing. And, uh, I was just like, Hey,
if you were a midsize company and you couldn't afford a red team like Google has, right. What
would be the package that you would want to really figure out if you could be breached? And we built
that into a service. So that's kind of where we are now. That's crazy. That, that sounds like such a,
a valuable product to the customer. Like that, that, and, and I think it's so awesome that you're
a part of crafting that too, because you have such an eclectic experience. You started in it, then you
moved into pen testing. So you got the internal, external pen testing side. You've done bug bounty,
which is just outside POC or GTFO. You've done a CISO. So you've seen all the attacks, the CISO of
a breached company. So you can see the, see all the attacks and the attack vectors. And then you take
all that experience, roll it up into one service and give it to the medium sized companies that can't
afford their own red team. Yep, exactly. And it's all, and it's usually for the price of what you would
spend on like, you know, one red team or two. So it's like, uh, pretty affordable. But like,
yeah, it's times like this, times like this, when I hear about this product that I'm like,
uh, like, why am I doing bug bounty? I love bug bounty. I absolutely love it. Every day that I do it.
Yeah. I get in there and I'm like hackity hackity and it's like, I just love it. So, but then I hear
about stuff like this and I'm like, wow, that is so, and, and don't get me wrong. Book bounty has a lot of
value. Adds. Oh yeah. I totally believe in the product. Yeah. But when I hear about stuff like
this and my entrepreneurial side just starts going and like my, just give amazing value to companies
side. So it's going and it just gets me hype man. Yeah. So one of the things that we add into, um,
we call it CAE or whatever, but, um, is actually we, we're looking for a better name, but we call it the
ringer and, um, the ringer is bringing in one of you guys twice a year. So my team of engineers
will, uh, we'll do, you know, our best and we will do a lot of recon up front to figure out the
technologies, whether they're SAS or, you know, infrastructure or whatever. Um, and then as part
of the built-in cost for the year long service, we bring in two specialized bug bounty hunters to work
with us on our butt-o-butt team for three weeks and we pay them up front. It's not pay for effort.
So yeah, yeah. Um, yeah, yeah. Uh, and so, um, I'm building a small, you know, a small stable of
people I really trust who are world-class engineers who can come on and just like be those extra eyes and,
uh, who I know are specialists in technology. And, you know, I know bug bounty hunters have been asking for
this, you know, for a long time, right? I mean, hacker one and bug crowd have their crowdsource pen
test, but this is, this is a lot of fun. Um, and I'm really only inviting people I know who are super
legit and, um, you know, like I've got Brett on speed dial for some stuff and, uh, yeah, and, uh, you
know, ZLZ and, you know, I'm obviously thinking about you guys, but, you know, bounty hunters are getting
tired of the, of the waste on my time and not get paid and get dicked around by the platform.
Yeah. Um, you know, kind of thing. And we're going to give it back to the bug bounty hunters and let
them get paid for their effort and work with the cool team and be an extension of our team here.
Cause I know the power of that. And so, uh, I mean like, you know, bug bounty platforms, look out,
I'm coming for you. That's all I got to say, I feel it though. And I think, I think there definitely is,
I mean, in, in a lot of ways, the attack surface is getting harder. Um, and in a lot of ways,
it's getting easier and there's, there's, there's a trade-off, you know, a lot more companies are
getting into bug bounty. So there's a lot more places to hack and a lot more things to go after,
but you know, as we evolve, the bug classes are starting, sort of disappearing. XSSI was,
I love the XSSI and that that's, that's gone now. And CSRF is still possible, but you know,
it's definitely a struggle now. Um, and so, you know, as we see these attack surfaces sort of, um,
sharing up a little bit, we have to pivot. And, and I think another big thing that would be really
helpful for bug bounty hunters or especially people that want to do like solo entrepreneur stuff is like,
have this thing with, with Jason, where, you know, you go and you do your moonlighting and you, you know,
do some pen test like work and that assures you, you're going to make your, however much.
Yeah. Your base or whatever. Yeah. Like, you know, make sure you're paying your bills and,
you know, feeding your family and that sort of thing. Yep. And then you get to spend your time,
you get your freedom, you get your, you know, to be your own boss and, you know,
you can go after whatever other targets you find interesting in the bug bounty space
and would do whatever research you want to do, which is where I find a lot of value in being a full-time
bug bounty hunter. Yeah, absolutely. And, um, you know, like we were, we were really hyped because,
uh, you know, like the bug bounty hunters are really good in the externals, but a lot of bug bounty
hunters don't get a lot of internal work. So like the active directory type of exploitation,
I miss that man. And, uh, and, you know, we, we do two of those, you know, in the package a year.
Um, or if we can pivot from external to internal, we find a bug that lets us do that.
Obviously we start doing that type of work and we do, we do two types. And so like being able to work
with some of the bug bounty hunters, I'm like getting back into that skillset. They're just like,
oh, this is refreshing. I get to do this kind of stuff. And, um, yeah, it's pretty, it's pretty cool.
So yeah, it absolutely is. All right. All right. So that's, that's the intro for you. Um, Joel,
where do you want to go from here? Dude, I, well, I have like, it's, you, you have such a really
diverse, like full background. It's really, really interesting to hear. I think I, I definitely relate
with a lot of the types of experiences that you've been through going from like hacker side to like
corporate side. And I'm very much so like on the corporate side currently. Um, and it's just very
interesting to hear you talk about sort of, um, a lot of the things that everybody within like
corporate security sort of talks about where it's like, you know, bug bounty is a thing that exists,
but it's like not a one size fits all solution. And it doesn't solve all the problems. It solves like
a select portion of the problems and like, it doesn't create a security team. It doesn't create
a culture of security within a company or anything like that. Joel, are you trying to tell me that I,
I, the bug bounty hunter and not the end all be all? What are you, what are you talking about?
Not to invalidate you too much. Yeah. So no, it's, it's really cool to hear that. Like,
you've taken all that, like experience and stuff and like turned it into something that you can help,
help like provide the companies. I was curious, is the only thing that, um, but about like provides,
is it purely sort of that like testing side or do you also provide like almost application security
as a service or that type of like guidance towards how to build better security teams and all that kind
of stuff. So, uh, one of the things that I'm like really, really good at, and it's, that's not really
like a bug bounty skill, but it's like offboarding and onboarding customers. Um, cause I, you know,
at bug crowd, I worked with probably over 250, you know, programs. And then at HP, I worked with the
majority of the fortune 100. And so, um, and you know, some of my best friends are VCSOs, which jump in
and out of companies all the time. So I have a very good pulse on like how to help them build a security
program. So in, in the reporting and, you know, this is a new company, right? So we're still building
out how this works, but in the offboarding, a whole month is dedicated with the head of the security
program, the sock, um, you know, whatever their team structure is like, right. If it's it or whatever
on, um, building the right security program with the focus of to not get breached basically, right?
Like I, I really appreciate application security and product security and all the other portions of
security and security programs and stuff like that. But really like the point of the service is like,
can you get breached? Right? Like, cause that's the nightmare for the CISO is, is like getting wrecked.
Um, and I've, I've had that nightmare. So I know, um, yeah, uh, so yeah, um, that's the point of it.
It's mostly testing, but at the end we offer like a month of kind of offboarding and it includes some
security. And like I said, we include things like if we have a successful attack path, we're going
to do atomic red team and atomic purple team tests. What does that mean? What is atomic red team,
atomic purple team? So you can think of the miter attack framework, which is a lot of what pen
testers and red teamers use these days to describe micro pieces of their methodology on how they
basically achieve their objectives. Um, and the way they do it is they take real threat actors and they
break down their methodologies into tiny little TTPs basically. And miter attack maps out all those
types and individual tests. And so, uh, basically, uh, atomic red team tests are small little bite
size code pieces. Um, a lot of times in PowerShell, but sometimes in other technologies that'll allow
you to replay one tiny little portion of attack to see if your sock can recognize it or train them
on recognizing it. Um, training, training the blue team to see various attacks while they're happening.
Exactly. Yeah. And so, uh, you know, so you sit with them and you're like, Hey, I'm gonna push the button
right now. Do you see it in Splunk? And they're like, yeah, I saw it. Like, okay, let's build that
alert and let's prioritize it, you know, correctly. And you know, how do you scale that across a 22,000
person business? And like, you know, so you, you kind of build out parts of their defensive nature.
Um, but we'll leave you for, you know, we'll be fixing code level vulnerabilities. Probably not. I
want to give, I want to give my customers the best I can, but I'm probably not going to consult with
them and, you know, fix app level code bugs. I'll, you know, I'll give them as much advice as I can,
but yeah, that's kind of where we'll be at. So I'd imagine, and Joel, you can probably shed some
more light on this, but I'd imagine that, you know, bringing in a third party to actually modify
your code base and stuff like that. I feel like that it's a little bit, you know, like, eh, because
you've got to kind of know the context of the application. And then you've got a, you've got all
this, you know, learning friction that you've got, um, you know, if you're bringing on a third party to
actually fix the code base. So, I mean, do you, do you see that Joel? I mean, yeah, I mean, I've had
discussions about this with, um, some of our mutual friends about like, does it make sense to think
about starting like a company that's basically AppSync as a service or PodSync as a service? And
the conclusion I came to is not really because an AppSync team needs to be bespoke. It needs to be
highly integrated. It needs to be like well-versed with the engineering team and like what they're
doing and what the infrastructure looks like and what the systems look like and what means
sensitive to that company. And you can, you can contract that out to some extent, but actually
building like a full fledged security team that has trust with the engineers and can like make actual
improvements throughout the whole ecosystem is really difficult from an outside perspective.
Yeah. Okay. So I'm going to show my, I'm going to show my true, you know, red team side here and
having done, you know, maybe a year of dev work, but outside of that, none. So the security teams at
these organizations, this, I'll throw this to both of you, but I want to hear from, from Joel first
year and then go over to Jason, cause he's got a wider variety of experience. Does the security team
actually have like, can you go in there and modify code or do you have to be like devs, please change
this, please, please? You know, like, how does that work?
So, so at least where I work, um, no, it's all like you have to, you would have to request like
write access to those repos to be able to, to like write. And even still like the most you could do
is probably open like a pull request. You couldn't actually make changes on, on main or anything like
that. Um, and I think that's like definitely for the better, obviously. Okay. I don't think you really
want your application security team to be pulling like into that space and trying to like become the
engineers, right? Because that's not really what their specialty is. Yeah. We, we could make code
changes that would probably be valid, but like that also means we have to learn like this repo and
the, the syntaxes and all the different coding, you know, whatever, like documentation and best
practices that they follow within that team or that repo or whatever. And we, we could try and replicate
that, but the amount of time it would take for us to do that versus saying, here's what you should
do and let the engineer who knows what they're doing, go ahead and take that. We've always found that
it's easier to just like guide and then like just verify. Right. Jason, do you, do you see that same
thing? Um, I mean, so if you break it into two, it's like, is there an opportunity for a consultancy
to do that? Uh, usually not. I've, I've had a couple of friends who have tried to bake it in
and, um, like onboard as longer term projects and bake in application security, but there is always a
culture clash of being a consultant. Um, and so it usually doesn't work like that, but there's some
examples that are, you know, like positive, at least that I can think of, but, um, as far as
internally and the way you structure your security team. So one of the things that was really successful
at, and I got this advice from, uh, um, a security leader, friend of mine, uh, Tony, he used to be,
uh, my Tinder. Um, but, uh, Tony was like the best thing I ever do was create a central
security engineering organization. Um, and so that's what I did at Ubisoft is I, you know, one of
the four branch big branches of our security team was this, um, kind of, uh, pick up the bat phone.
This is a priority application, bring on, um, four or five app sec engineers, and they would onboard
with you for six months at a time and basically be part of your team. And they, you know, they,
they got billed to your team. Um, and so they would sit with you, they would go to stand-ups,
you know, they're part of the, you know, all of the, you know, dev infrastructure and everything
like that. And then they would start fixing vulnerabilities themselves after, um, you know,
a little while. And then we would have to do that by priority because we had 60 products, but
eventually we started burning down really big systemic issues. And then we could move on to
categories of non-systemic issues that were priority and then the medium priority. And so we had this
like strike team that we could apply and it was, you know, it became very, very, very successful inside
of Ubisoft. And so I think that whole org was broken up into, uh, security engineering was broken up into
security architects, which helped design systematic fixes basically. Um, which, you know, we had a,
we had two cloud architects on different technologies. We had kind of our legacy technologies
guy. We had a guy who knew the network really well. And like the topology, we had an API guy,
and then we had a couple of guys who were just devs in the coding languages of whatever, um, that we,
you know, most of our productions used. Um, and then we had a consultant team, um, who were trainers
and threat modelers, and they would onboard with products. And, um, and then we had, um, we had a couple
other of like, just like people on the team, but I think it was a total team of maybe 15.
Um, and they helped a lot of people in that model. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But I mean, it can make a big
impact, honestly. So, um, yeah, so they, they onboarded and were really successful. And I like
that strike team type of mentality. Um, you know, if you have the budget for it inside of an organization.
Very cool. So would you say that there are like any like major key takeaways that you
still pull on like a day-to-day basis from like your hacker experience going into like a C-suite
experience and then also from like your previous, like running a security team to now being like head
of security? Uh, yeah, absolutely. I would, I mean, there's a ton of valuable lessons. In fact,
um, I get myself in trouble a lot, uh, because I call a lot of CISOs, haha CISOs or business CISOs.
Uh oh. Um, at conferences and stuff because they've never actually done security. I mean,
they'll come from like risk management or they'll come from, you know, some have come from like
marketing or something like that. It's like, these are executives and having the executive skill set and
being able to present to the board and speak well is absolutely a key feature you need, you know,
to be in this, in this role. But, uh, I believe the future lies with technical CISOs, people who
understand at at least like a medium level, uh, what the attacks are and, um, and you know, you use that
to guide your security program. So I, you know, I was on a panel a couple of weeks ago here in Denver
with, you know, two guys who were very eloquent. They dressed very nicely. I'm in my hoodie up
there on stage and they're talking about like all these security programs. And I'm like, man,
I would just not invest in that. Right. That's not a thing that's going to get us breached. Like,
that is a thing that like, I guess you, you're, you're running metrics on just to make yourself feel
good. Right. Um, and so it's not practical. It's not practical at all. Yeah. Um, and so like,
yeah, I get in trouble because I call them ha ha CISOs. Um, I, I, when I worked at a, at a previous,
my previous consultancy, I worked for center common, Wisconsin also do something very similar,
by the way, to your, your, you know, full scale, um, you know, simulation of, uh, adversaries.
Nice. Um, but I, I went with them to RSA, you know, and I, I was at the booth, you know,
talking to people and stuff like that. And I can't tell you how many times people came over and were like,
wow, look at this guy. He's like actually talking about like hands on attack vectors and stuff like
that. And so on one of my breaks, I was kind of walking around and like looking at some of the
other places there and there's just so many like crap products out there, man. It's like, and, or,
and even if the product has merit, you know, there's the, the people that are there, you know,
doing the talking and stuff like that, you know, if you try to poke a little bit deeper at a technical
level, it gets a little bit tricky. So it is definitely refreshing to see, um, you know,
someone technical in those positions. And I think it's also fairly rare as well, you know?
Um, but it's, I also feel like it's not as, after being in the bug bounty community,
after going to the live hacking events, I also feel like it's not as rare as people make it out to be.
Like got, you know, we're, we're all, we're all hackers. We're doing our, our hackity thing,
but like a decent amount of the people at the live hacking events are also like really cool and
really eloquent and like really like well-spoken and all of the like show and tells that happen
are like really well done, uh, you know, most of the time. And so, um, I think there's definitely
some space for, uh, you know, hackers to be utilized in, in sales and marketing a little bit stronger.
And, and I'm, I'm just, you know, whether it aligns with their goals or not, or their desires or not,
that's a different story, but, um, the capability is definitely there, I think.
Yeah. I think that, um, I think specifically Joel on, on the questions, like, you know,
what specifically translated, um, it was more focused on like the technical bugs that I thought could lead
to both breaches of private information and, uh, and, you know, breaches from external, internal.
I really wanted that also the, um, although it's a saturated market, I feel because it all came from
bug bounty, but, you know, having a risk register and an asset identification plan is really important
to organizations. So like, you know, tax surface management and stuff like that, right? Like
if you think about like how much stuff gets found in the bug bounty scene because of recon
and recon came out of bug bounty and now it's like this, you know, multi-million dollar
industry that platforms are spawning up around. And so, um, you know, like I think that's important.
Like you can't defend what you don't know about in a security program. So like you have to have,
um, you know, some kind of centralized place. And so I'm a, I'm a big fan. They're vulnerable,
like strict vulnerability management. I didn't think was as important until I married the two goals,
right? Like nothing's worse than just having a backlog full of bugs. You're never going to fix,
right? It has to be prioritized. It has to be clean. Um, these are all things that you have
to have a strong program around, um, which bug bounty is a portion of finding vulnerabilities,
right? So it fits in there under vulnerability management and operations. And, um, and then I
think, you know, I, I think just, uh, also, um, what else did I bring from my hacker life? I don't know.
Yeah. I was going to say, so like, we're, we're all about the technical stuff here and
this is not one of the questions that we, you know, I sent to you beforehand. So this is like raw,
raw, but like, for example, you know, you said focusing on practices that are going to limit,
you know, personal information disclosure and stuff like that. So are we talking about like,
okay, we need, we have to get rid of these numeric IDs and switch to UU IDs, or we, you know,
we have to, uh, you know, install access control at like a middleware or something like that. I don't
know what the practices are. Cause once again, I'm, I'm a hacker, not a, not a dev, but like,
you know, uh, we're talking about those sorts of things. Yeah. I mean, where, where, okay. Well,
I mean the first thing that's going to reduce like anything at a security program, when you drop in
as a VC or CISO, right. Is, is authentication changes, which is two factor authentication. If
you can get FIDO rolling a number of breaches, you know, I would say, I'm going to say 80% or more
have some sort of credential reuse component to them these days. And so, uh, you focus hard on that.
Um, although a lot of people love to hate an EDR, if you don't have an EDR strategy, you got to have
some sort of EDR. Um, and, uh, you know, a lot of people hate on SIM too, but you got it. Like
there are table stakes for a security program, but when you come with an offensive mindset, yes, you get
into the cloud world, you get into, um, IAM for cloud, you get into configuration management for cloud.
Um, you get into, yes, architecting systems where you're not, uh, doing access control, um, badly,
you know, which means like mitigating a lot of EDR type attacks. Um, you know, in a video game
company specifically, we had to focus a lot on not leaking data, uh, that was pre-release or post-release,
but private, you know, that could help cheaters and stuff like that. So, um, we focused a lot on,
on cloud leaks and stuff like that. So, um, yeah, that's, that's cool, man. And, and, and I appreciate
giving, giving that context, even though it's kind of a surprise question and the pieces are always
really, really, you know, once you get your eyes on it, you start seeing the holes, but it's not
necessarily like, you know, Jason opens up his little book and he's like, all right, you know,
you know, every numeric idea needs to be, you know, yeah, no, no, you, you got to take it piece by piece.
Right. Yeah. Yeah. So I w I wanted to dive in on, on some of the like recon and asset discovery
stuff you were talking about, but before we did that, I actually wanted to just ask about
one thing that we had briefly talked about, which is, um, you know, the skill within sort of the
hacker community. Right. So like, we're all hackers. Um, I think we all know a ton of like really,
really talented people from the bug bounty space, especially. Yeah. Um, and having like transition
from hacking to like full-time back to hacking, hacking and full-time all that kind of stuff. Yeah.
Like, do you have any tips on like how to hire some of those amazing talent sources? Like how
do you pull someone from bug bounty into the like corporate space? How do you get them to go full-time?
Yeah. I mean, um, you got to give, so people who are full-time bug bounty, who are really,
really good, uh, sometimes come with, you know, personality. And so you've got to be a manager who
can foster personality, I think. Um, and let them kind of spread their wings. Uh, I was,
I won't say which job it was, but, um, one of my jobs, right? Like, like I am very ADD and, um,
and I will go off on like some project and dive really deep into it. And then like, you know, like,
uh, but it might not be the thing I'm supposed to be doing at that time. And so people, uh, one of the
people at my work put up this sign in their office and they said, let Jason be Jason. Uh, it was
actually let jihadics be jihadics. Um, and, um, and so you got to kind of treat people like that,
right? Like, you know, like let them focus on, as long as they're bringing value with their focus,
you got to let them, uh, you know, spread their wings. I mean, as far as monetary, right? It's
really hard because some of those people, when they are ready to transition, they're looking at,
I don't know if you guys talk about money on, on this podcast, but I mean, they're, I mean,
you're looking at like a, a world-class bug bounty hunter is not going to take a job at a company
for less than $250,000. And sometimes where some of the fan companies or MAGA companies now,
whatever they're called, um, that's 500 K, uh, total package, you know, and sometimes maybe even base,
you know, 450 and then total package is like 600, 700, 800. Plus, you know, you've got crazy bonuses
every year. Um, they're just really expensive, some of the great talent. And so like, if you're
looking to bring in someone like that, but you're not one of those companies, you got to have an epic
culture. You got to have interesting clients. You got to have an epic service, right? That allows them
to learn and grow. You got to have leadership who understands them. Um, and, uh, you know, that's
kind of what I'm trying to build at, at ButtoBot, right? It's like, uh, you know,
hopefully I'll see some of the new up and coming, you know, bug hunters come work for us and be
offensive security engineers. Um, and you got to offer stability too, right? Like if you can't meet
the package, well, what, what are things that you can do, um, that can't meet a package of like a
Google, right? And that is like, it's, it's portions of culture. It's, you know, like I did this whole
talk on, um, on how to, but when we were in the great, basically, uh, resignation phase last year,
before we were into the great firing phase. Now, um, I did a talk at black hat at the CISO summit.
And it was, it was like how to basically keep your employees in an ever competitive market.
And, you know, at shadow labs, you know, we had this great program where we would induct people
into shadow labs once a year at an award ceremony. We'd give them all this bad-ass swag,
very similar to what hacker one does at a live event. Um, but it was exclusive.
It was for your contribution to the team. We were doing hack Fridays. We focused,
we over-indexed on training each other and being like a family. Um, and like, those are intangibles,
right? Like, uh, and they cost nearly nothing, honestly, like swag is a, is a penny on the dollar
compared to, you know, anything and really having some swag, right? I'm not going to lie.
Right. I'm repping the, right. I mean, so you see people walking
around with bug crowd or hacker one hoodies or people who work at really reputable shops,
you know, who do pen testing or whatever, and they have these brands and you would be surprised
at how powerful those brands are to make you feel included and like family and accepted because
we're all nerds, right? And we all have these small little quirks of like, you know, like,
am I good enough? We all have imposter syndrome. Um, and, uh, and so if you can cultivate that vibe,
that family, um, you know, cutting edge vibe, you can get some of those people against Google
and Netflix and, you know, those places and stuff like that. Yeah, man. I have to say like that,
that rings so true for me. And I, I tell you, so I worked at Cindercom before I mentioned them before,
um, in Wisconsin. And like I, like I said, you know, I was, it's, it's a smaller consultancy and I was,
I was making, you know, a good amount for a junior pen tester, you know, because they got me right out
of college right into there. And, uh, but you know, my bug bounty income, you know, quickly started
surpassing that and, but I didn't, I didn't leave for a while. And, um, and the reason why is, is
just like, it was just such a good community. It was such a great place to work. And like the people
that I was around were awesome. And so at the end, when I, I did leave, the reason I left was because,
uh, it was Mariah's dream, my wife's dream to move to Japan. And, um, you know, I couldn't keep the
same schedule, you know, work schedule if I was in Japan. So I was like, all right, you know,
I'm going to pull the trigger and go, but, um, that was one of the hardest things I've ever done,
man. Like he was so hard leaving that company. And, and, um, and so, yeah, I think there's definitely,
it's definitely possible, you know, speaking from a full-time boat bounty perspective, you know,
if you can, if you can entice that, if you can show that amount of, um, culture, that amount of,
you know, I don't know, there's just a good feel. I don't know how to describe it, but there's a good
feel, then you can really pull the talent for sure. Yeah. So I pulled, I pulled up some of the
slides from the talk, right? So usually the things that are set in stone for a company trying to
attract our base range, equity range, yearly bonus and benefits. Those are kind of set in stone for
the company. You know, you know, them before going into negotiation, but what are negotiated,
what are negotiated really is hiring bonus. So you can, you can usually negotiate a higher hiring
bonus for someone, um, uh, PTO, right? Like PTO actually can be negotiated, right? Like how much
actual time off do you get to cut off, you know, a year, uh, work from home obviously is a big one
nowadays, right? Like the promise to, to stay in your own space. If you want to, you know, uh, four
day work week is becoming more and more popular. Like, uh, you know, to, to have that three day weekend
also is pretty baller. I've done it before where it's big, man. Yeah. You get to spend a lot more time with
your family, like a bigger chunk with your family. And then like intrinsic is like how much travel
training are you going to make people do? Um, you know, the, the idea of the 80, 20 work, uh,
work project kind of cycle that Google does write 80% time on your job, 20% time of your time can be
spent on building tools or contributing to community another way or learning. Um, and then I'm just a big
component of flex time, which a lot of people don't like, but, um, a lot of like managing people don't
like, but I like, as long as you're doing your work, if you, if you ever call me and I'm your boss
and you're like, Hey, I'm going to, I'm going to go to like, you know, like do this cool thing that
just came up. Right. I'm like, yeah, go do it. Like, you know, like take the day off, take, you know,
tomorrow off or whatever, as long as we're getting our projects done and our deliverables done and you
don't have like a, a thing. Like I just consider that some nights I'm working until like 10 o'clock,
you know, because I'm in the zone. I'm, you know, I'm going, you know, like, and I don't want to stop
working. And so people talk about this hustle and grind mentality, but I think of it more as like
flexible time, right. Where you can put in, you know, maybe 10 hours one day and then only put in
two another day. And in actuality, tech workers work like that anyway. So just making it official
is like, is, is such a relief for many people. They're just like, Oh, Jason, Jason knows I want to go to
this rave thing. And like, I'm going to be back in a couple of days and I'm not going to have my phone
on. He'll cover for me. And like, um, you know, or something like that. And then mentorship is the
last one I have on my list is just like strong mentorship. Like, you know, Joel's on my team and
he wants to be the CISO level, right? Like I am going to meet with Joel every week and be like,
where are we with your goals to get to this level that you want to get to? How can I help you?
You know, where do I have feedback and mentorship is really, really big. And the leaders spending time
mentoring is really important. Like you have to take the time out of your day to mentor people.
Otherwise they will, they will, you know, become disconnected basically.
Dang, man. That's, that's gold. That's, I mean, that was like a little mini masterclass
in how to be a good manager.
Yeah, that was like, that was fire, dude. I will say, yeah, one thing about the flex time
really quick. I want to jump back to that. Like I, I recently, so as a, as a full-time bug bounty hunter,
I've had a couple of my friends that are, are wanting to make the jump, um, hit me up and be like,
Hey, can we set, sit down and have a chat, you know, and figure out whether this is a right fit
for me. I was like, sure. So we, I get on a call with them. And, um, one of the things, you know,
I talked to these people, like you said, you know, salaries are pretty good in some of these companies.
And, you know, you can make a chunk as a full-time bug bounty hunter, if you're,
if you're skilled for sure. Um, even more so than, you know, probably what I would be getting
in the industry right now, if I went in and worked as in, you know, in just with my experience level
and such like that. But, um, you know, the big thing for me is, is the flex is the flexibility.
Right. Um, and so, you know, I'm talking to these guys and I'm like, Hey, you know, what, well, what's
the, what's the value add for going, um, you know, full-time bug bounty for you. So let's, let's assume
the money is roughly the same, you know, for your first year, you know, you haven't hit your stride
as a full-time bug bounty hunter or whatever. Let's assume it's, it's, it's roughly the same.
Um, what, why is this better than what you're currently doing? And then the primary answer
I get back is like, my work workplace is fairly flexible. So if I say like, Hey, I need to go run
to a doctor's appointment or I need to go, you know, go on a walk with my kid or something like that.
Like they're, they're like, sure, go for it. But like, I have to check in, you know? And, and, and like,
like you said, you know, making that sort of small flex things official as a part of the company,
I think that would be huge. And I think that would allow them to retain talent, you know,
in these sorts of situations, because my friends are like, yeah, you know what, for me, if I want
to just stand up and go get in my hot tub or like, you know, go on a walk or like, you know,
something like that, I don't want to have to tell someone about that. Or if I need to go, you know,
drop my lawnmower off at Home Depot to get fixed, you know, like very specific situation here.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Speaker 1: You know, then, you know, I don't want to have to check in with somebody to do it. I just
want to do it, you know? And I totally, I totally feel that. So, you know, making that more official,
making that more, you know, as part of the company culture would be huge to retain talent, I think.
Speaker 1: Awesome. Awesome. Cool. All right. Well, that was a little bit of a,
more of a tangent than I thought it was going to be, but it was chock full of awesome information.
Speaker 1: I did want to circle back to like, um, the asset discovery stuff that you're talking
about, right? So like, obviously that's like a huge part of the stuff that like you've done,
both from your history, the, uh, bug hunters methodology, like all that kind of stuff.
Speaker 1: Mm-hmm.
Speaker 1: How much does your personal, like hunting and personal strategy shift away from
the stuff that you've published and talked about? Is it basically just one-to-one with bug
hunters methodology? Do you basically just like throw your public word list on the ferricks buster
and go for it or how does it work?
Speaker 1: Sometimes I do. Um, I mean, it really depends on, on the target, right? Like,
so like some of the recon methodology is totally invalidated if there's just one host in the bug
bounty, right? Like, uh, so, you know, it depends on what programs I'm invited to. I do prefer the larger
recon-y like, uh, friendly, um, things because I have a couple methods that are not published in my
decks that still find me like really good stuff. And, um, and all the public stuff still finds me stuff
too. So, um, yeah, I mean, I would say I'm a heavy recon based hunter, which I know is not popular these
days, but that's okay. Um, I just really find old shit that people leave on the internet. Like, that's my
skill. I don't know why. Like, um, and I'm not telling everybody else they have to, that needs to
be their skillset. And I still hack apps and like all that stuff like that. But, um, yeah, I mean, like,
uh, I mean, my, when I sit down to a program, right? Like, let's say, you know, this week is the, um,
is the hacker one, um, you know, like a world cup, right? And, um, I'm, I'm on a team with Justin and,
uh, are Joel, are you playing? Are you in the other team?
Yeah. No, I'm on that one. Okay. We're all on the same channel. Okay. I was on vacation when
you guys started. So I'm like trying to like do stuff, but it wasn't really like I was still on
vacation. So I'm going to, I'm going to dive into this week. Yeah. Yeah. Anyway. So, yeah. I mean,
like when I looked at that list, I was like, all right, who's going to have like a lot of assets
that I will be beneficial for. Right. And so like tonight I'm going to fire up all my automation,
um, on my VPS is in my new axiom set up and I'll start, you know, doing recon and then,
you know, like after I get done with recon, I think people just make this jump though,
when I give those talks, especially the recon one, they're like, oh, recon is going to find me bugs.
And that is not, that's where it falls apart, right? Like recon doesn't really find you bugs.
What Jason? Yeah. Like, so, so I use recon and I give all these esoteric methods of recon and I make
a whole talk about recon to find more apps to hack. Like that is the point. Find more apps because the more
apps you find, the more of a chance you have to succeed in hacking. Right. And so like,
that has always been my thing. Right. Fine. Give myself more at bats. Like if you're a baseball
person or whatever. Right. Like, and so like, yeah, the recon for me, like stops at subdomain
enumeration usually. Right. Every once in a while, a nuclei template will hit and it's not a dupe.
That's like once every six months or something like that. Right. Like I use it to find the subs and then
I do the application hacking. And then, so like, if you want to break recon into kind of content
discovery and stuff like that. Yeah. I mean, I have word lists, my all.txt. Um, I've been using, um,
uh, six, two, does is new word list that kind of combines all the, all the word lists of the same
before. What is that? Um, it's called all for one, I think. Um, yeah, it's a, it's a word list.
Did you say the name? Was it six, four? Six, four, does he's the guy who writes recon for the win?
Um, yeah. Uh, I will, I will find it right now. Yeah. If you could, yeah. That, that sounds
real interesting. Okay. So he does one called one list for all that's his project. One list for all.
Yeah. Um, and so he's the, he's the author of, um, of recon for the win, but he basically did what
I did, but updated it. And, um, you know, what I did with the all list is basically I went back
through the 15 years I've been hacking and found all of the tools that did content discovery, basically,
uh, you know, file and directory brute forcing. And I just combined them into one word list. And yeah,
there was a lot of trash in there, but it was full coverage of everything. Everybody had done research
on for that topic of content discovery. So he did the same thing. Um, and it's a huge list, but I mean,
like, uh, I, I find stuff with it all the time because it's agnostic to technology. Um, and it
includes a lot of legacy stuff. And I'm not, I'm not, this is not a burn at anybody who's a younger
tester, but you weren't around for if you're testing a legacy org organization, right? Um, and so, you
know, in the, that's why people are like, oh, why, you know, like, why does this hit, why does it not
hit anything for me? Well, if you're using it against like a cloud first organization, none of that
shit in there is going to work, right? You need it. You need a better word list. And, uh, you know,
that's targeted towards that technology. But if you're targeting an older company, like my word list
kills against Yahoo, because they still have a lot of legacy tech, um, you know, or like a, a Walmart or
something like that, like that, that word list has killed against Walmart, even though they, they suck
sometimes. Yeah. That's the thing. I've also had that experience. Um, I, you know, I, that's why I
really like, you pointed out something really, really important there that I just wanted to re-highlight,
which was like you, if you're, if you're throwing, you know, this, these lists at like a, you know,
an S3 bucket, you know, you're not going to get anything. Um, and so like, you definitely got to
keep an eye out on that and, and make sure you're not just wasting your, your CPU cycles. Yeah,
exactly. That's one of the reasons I love asset notes, word lists that they put out as well. Yep.
Just like absolutely phenomenal. Yep. Um, and the UI is pretty too. Oh yeah. It's great.
Word list. Yeah. So that's, I mean, they're the leaders in content discovery lists right now. Um,
I mean, before them, they, we had S me and digger and get digger, which was by, um, some other
consultancies, but they are the leader now and, uh, long live shubs, who is probably one of the
smartest, smartest human beings and most compassionate men I've ever met in my life. He's, he's phenomenal.
Yeah. I've, I've had some legit mental health struggles in the last couple of years and I've,
I've messaged shubs just feeling like a fricking noob. And he has talked me down a couple of times
and just been like, yo, we're all like that. And, um, he's, he's an amazing person. That's,
that's what I'll say. So, yeah, he's an amazing guy. He's been through like so many different things
personally and he just has a lot of amazing insights on so many things. Uh, I want to, I want to pull him
on the shows. Yeah. Yeah. I want to pull him on the podcast too. Oh yeah. Yeah. That'd be,
it'd be great to have him on here. I got to hit him up.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Just make sure you, you explore more than the tech with him. Cause he's
got so many layers, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, so it sounds like a lot of the time you end up
using just sort of all that TXT do just literally like content discovery, find interesting targets.
And then from there it's all like, it's web hacking. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I mean, yeah. I mean,
if, if I could describe the rest of it, right? Like, um, okay. So I'm in, I'm in burp,
everything is through burp for me, right? Uh, I'm not one of the kind of guys who uses
like dev tools. Um, I find it too cluttered. So I mostly pipe everything through burp. Um,
and then I'm just using the site like a normal user. If there's multiple roles executing all the
functions I can making sure I hit the deep areas of like, uh, once a user logs in their configurations
or settings panels, any API integrations. And I talked about this in my newest bug hunters methodology.
I got way more into the app hacking, um, stuff. And so, uh, I look at those and then I think about
an application as its inputs, which I've kind of been trained as for many, many years. Right. And so
there are heat areas and application anywhere that handles a URL or path, you know, has the potential
for certain classes of bugs. Any place that handles a reflected piece of text has class, you know, has
possibilities for certain types of bugs. And so what I'll usually do is I'll look at the site tree
or I'll use burps dynamic, uh, analysis, uh, in pro to look at all of the dynamic parameters
and I'll see what's there and what got passed to them. And then I'll start fiddling with them.
Um, and I have a checklist to make sure that I'm looking for all bug classes that relate to the
types of inputs. So file uploads. Um, and then I'll key in on things like JSON and XML response types,
because those are usually associated to web services sometimes. And then I'll move into web hacking
mode or web service hacking mode or API mode. And yeah. And so, I mean,
that's pretty much the regular type of app sec bug hunter testing workflow. I think, um, I just have,
you know, 15 years of knowledge on, uh, you know, which I did that project of what parameters are most
likely vulnerable to which things. Um, and so that, that is one of my superpowers. Like I can look,
right? Yeah. Hunt. Yeah. Um, which is imported to like several different tools now, but, um,
that has really helped me in my testing over the years. So, yeah, I'm going to pull up hunt really quickly,
and I'm going to put that in my notes and then I've got, here it is. I've got a question for you.
Yeah. Um, so, well, first of all, I just wanted to go back and highlight, um, you know, what you said
before, um, you know, the, the dynamic analysis piece that you, that you reflected on, um, in, you know,
inside of burp, I want to know how you, how you did that. Um, and then also I, for, for the people
listening, just kind of talking about methodology, you said, you know, there are types of bug classes
that appear when, you know, URLs are being handled, there's types of bug classes that appear when
content is being reflected. This is the sort of thing that you just kind of gain a sixth sense for
when you're an experienced tester. Yeah. Um, and, and so like, I just wanted to go back and highlight
those two things because like, and, and I, I think, you know, uh, people ask me this all the time. Do you
have like a checklist that you kind of go through and stuff like that? And for a long time, the bug
bunny hunters methodology or the bug hunters methodology was that for me. And you know, you've
got some other stuff out there with checklists. I think that's great, but as I have evolved as a
hacker and maybe this is different and I know some people that do checklists and do it very well,
but for me, it becomes more stuff like that. Like, like this, okay. There's a URL being parsed here.
Uh huh. There's a variety of weird things that can happen when the URL is being parsed. There's a
variety of things that can happen when a regex is being used. There's a variety of weird things that
can be happening when there's reflected content and those sort of like sort of risk areas. If you guys
can focus on, on those sorts of things and gain, you know, a sense for like when pitfalls happen at a
general level, I think, I think that's going to really help, you know, people level up as a, as hackers,
because that's what gets you off the checklist and more thinking like as an attacker methodology,
attacker mentality, going into the application, looking at it, feeling it, you know, I always talk
about feeling it, you know, getting intimate with the application, understanding all the different
pieces, the way data flows through it and where the sketchy things happen. And so here's the level up from
that that, you know, people eventually grow into, but, uh, and I saw you do it the other day. Someone put
something in our hack, uh, in our hack channel for the competition. Yeah. And you're like, well, they're
using this language, so they're probably using this parser or this library, right? And so like people
always talk about, understand the technology, right? And so the, the maturation of a tester is, okay,
I understand that this happening in the URL can be indicative of these bugs. And then the next level
is like, oh, because they're using this coding language or they're hosting it here, or I've done
some research on the company or whatever, I know that they're using the stack. And this is the thing
that's probably handling that URL. And here now I'm going to go Google, hey, what have the bugs been in
the past? Is there a way I can bypass this thing? Has there been preexisting research, you know,
that'll help me in my exploitation of this type of bug, you know, of whether it's a URL parser or a
file upload parser, you know, or whatever. Um, that's like the next step is like being a technology
specialist and, and being able to do that in a short time too, because like, you know, you only have so
long to hack an app if you're in a pen test or a bug bounty, right? So yeah. Yeah, absolutely. So the
dynamic analysis piece, um, you know, you said you were using burp to figure out that, um, I, I, I'm not,
you know, a burp super pro, um, what, what are you using for that? Uh, so let me see here. Let me pull
up real quick. Um, I know there's like reflected parameters. So reflected parameters is a, oh, it's
not an extension. It's base. It's in the base, um, policies now for burp. So, um, so really I don't
ever think honestly, and, and I'll, I'll just be totally honest about this, right? I don't ever think
I'm going to do probably a better job than Burp's dynamic scanner with cross-site scripting. So I just
have one, I have one policy in Burp that checks for cross-site scripting across the whole site and
I only run it on dynamic parameters, which I get by, I will tell you right now, right clicking on the
targets. Yeah. Um, and you go, uh, hold on. Uh, yeah, I want to, I want to poke around at it and see,
because there's like analyze target, which I don't use very often. Yes, that's it. It's analyst target.
Yeah. It's analyst target. So you right click on a host and you choose, uh, engagement tools,
analyze target, and then you go to dynamic URLs and that's everything that has passed data, um,
against the site. And so that really trims down like all of the, you know, static content and
everything. And that's, that's kind of where I focus after I've done a full walkthrough of the app.
Now it doesn't always work, right? Like single page applications are not gonna, you know,
they're not gonna like work the same way. And, um, you know, yeah, but, but for in general,
most sites who, who pass data, you know, via post requests will, you know, uh, will be there and
even get requests to where it sees like a larger payloads, um, or, you know, larger URLs or parameters
in the URL or things that thinks are rest parameters. It will, it will count as dynamic.
And so you look at dynamic URLs and then you can check each dynamic URL for what params it sent.
And you just start analyzing like that basically.
Dude, that's, that's gold, man. I, I, I always find new cool pieces of burp when I talk to,
you know, amazing testers that I, that I respect. And yeah, it's, it's so great to,
to get everyone's way that they use this tool. Yeah. And, uh, yeah, I, and Kaido is going to be
making, you know, its own, there's going to be those same things in Kaido as well. There's a
couple of features that Kaido has already that I just, I love that are, that are not in burp,
particularly I'll call this one out. I hate how in burp, when you intercept, you have to click
forward, forward, forward, forward, forward, forward, forward, until you find the request you're
looking for. Yeah. In Kaido, it queues them all up. Okay. And then you can just like,
you can jump when you want. Oh, that's cool. That's very cool.
Oh my gosh. It's just a game changer. Yeah. So a lot of the times I end up just,
you know, right clicking, say, always accept from this host, because it's always like adding
analytics frameworks, loading and like all kinds of like APIs that I'm not testing, but I end up having
to do that process like 10 times. And I'm like, Oh my God. Yeah. The one part that I will say is you
can do some adjustments on the, on the interception side. So where it says like, intercept these requests,
either from the client, like the requests or the responses, you can say it has to meet certain criteria.
So I'll often say like, it has to be within my defined scope and yeah. And maybe I'll add
like an extra condition. Like it needs to match this path or it needs to be on this host or something.
So that it'll only like, yeah, I might have to click forward a couple of times, but it would be less
than it would be like with all the tracking pixels and everything.
The thing is, is that like, I've known about that trick for a while and I use it. I literally am
looking at it checked right now. Um, the, the, uh, is in target scope, request intercept rule. Um,
but the thing is I do a lot of, um, right lately, I've been doing a lot of client side stuff. Um, and,
uh, sometimes I'll be, you know, poking out how they enter, they interact with like, you know,
third-party libraries and what kind of stuff they're loading in and what kind of JavaScript they're,
they're trusting, you know, to run on their page. Um, and so sometimes I do want to hit
intercept things that are outside of my scope and type like uncheck it. And then I check it and then
uncheck it and I check it. And, you know, burp did a good job of, I think, putting that settings
panel in a different, um, window now, uh, the latest version of burp. Um, so you can kind of keep it
up and you know, on one of your monitors or something like that, if you want to, but, um,
yeah, still, still a pain point for me, I must say. So the, the other part of the question I think
was like, it was like fuzzing. I think you were trying to get at it and like, you know, so I have,
I have sec lists. I have a couple other fuzzing projects, like the awesome fuzzing project on
GitHub, but web fuzzing is part of my workflow. Um, so it's not just parameter analysis. And I have
like this thing that I remember in my head, it's like, um, it's, uh, sensitive secrets were leaked
recently. And it's an acronym for how I basically think about, um, when I fuzz with random data,
either big payloads, small payloads, you know, different type of attack payloads, uh, as a, you know,
either a, a rest, um, request or a parameter request, parameter value request. Um, I look at the status
code, the size, the words, the line, and the return time, basically. And so in each of those,
I'm looking for different things. So it's sensitive secrets were leaked recently. So status code,
write it down. Sensitive secrets were leaked recently. Status code, size, words, lines, return
time lines. Okay. And so, so with status code, obviously you're looking, you want to focus in on
the app anytime you get a non non-standard status code. Right. And so you learn these as you test,
right. You said it yourself, like this is years of testing condensed into like an acronym, right. But,
but basically status code, you know, any errors I want to over index on to see how I cause that error
with my fuzzing payloads and what payload was it, um, with my size, I want to see, you know,
you'll get non-standard return sizes, right. So you want to sort the column and burp by return,
or, uh, return size of the, of the binary payload of the return of the HTTP request.
Lines also can be indicative of new content was loaded on the page while you were testing that maybe
you, you got access to, especially error reports that leak credentials or things like that. Like
error messages that just dump on the screen and stuff. Um, return time shows, you know,
the indicative of less of like a parser or something like that. Um, you know, taking too much time to
parse a file or a fuzzing payload, you gave it. And then that's something you want to test for,
like, you know, DOS or application DOS or something like that, or, you know, um, you know, a myriad of
other bugs, but, uh, yeah, that's kind of how I look at, at all responses and analyze them when I'm
doing like actual fuzzing. So dude, it's kind of crazy, man. Like I, I, um, I think one of the mistakes
that I made earlier in my, in my career was I was working with a lot of people that were older than
me and that were my senior in organizations and I found them not technical. And so I,
I really just kind of dissed that, you know, I was like, you know what, you know, I'm, I am,
I'm the generation that, you know, understood, you know, that I grew up with computers and stuff
like that. And then I meet like a couple edge cases like you and fronds and people like that,
that are just like, you know, a little bit above me, but also like, you know, in age-wise,
but it just like have been doing the same thing for years and years and years. And then I just get
like blown away by like, Oh yeah, I've got this acronym that I just pulled off at the top of my head about
how I, you know, it's like, what the heck? Like, so dude, it's, it's such a pleasure to, to get you
on here and talking about this stuff and, and see, you know, what it can look like, you know,
as experienced compounds experience plus interest in, in Buck Downey and hacking compound over time.
And you can combine that with, with James Kettle's backslash powered scanner. So that will, that will do
fuzz testing of all the special characters and then backslash escape them. And so you use that acronym
sensitive secrets were re we're leaked recently with that to kind of get custom fuzz cases for web
applications. That's, that's awesome, dude. Yeah. I, that's one of the areas that I, I think I need to
progress in as a hacker is fuzzing and, and, uh, you know, I I'm finding this right now where at the
target that I'm looking at for the world cup, I'm trying to find, I've got a very specific narrow
scope that I've locked myself down to. And I say, I've got to find every single functionality that
this website has. Um, and for that, you've got a fuzz because you know, you're, you know, you can pull
gal, you can pull, you know, anything and, and like, you're still not going to find the stuff that,
you know, the very large percentage of stuff that somehow doesn't get, you know, put in archive or like
virus total or whatever it pulls from. Um, and so, yeah, fuzzing is definitely an area that I would
like to, I would like to level up on. Yep. Um, all right, Joel, we are at one hour, 20 minutes.
I could talk to Jason forever. I mean, I got time if you guys want to do it. I think,
I think we may actually make this like a very long episode, uh, cause I still got a couple other
things. I want to hear about your reports for sure. Um, Joel, do you have anything you want to hit
before we get to the reports? No, not, nothing important. I feel like we've done a really good
job of sort of covering like most of the questions that we had come up with in some pretty natural flow.
Cool. Cool. All right. So Jason, this is, this is, um, you know, this is something we
want to try to hit with people that come onto the podcast. Um, one of the big things we do here is
kind of talk about reports and like getting the weeds of technical vulnerabilities, which you just
did a great job of doing, doing a great job of doing both on the soft skills size and, and on the
technical side, which is phenomenal. Um, but yeah, I, I hit you up in advance, you know,
provide some reports. So let's, uh, let's, well, first actually, let me ask this. Do you have a
particular favorite bug type that you've got or like, you know, so some bug type where you just
like, Oh, I love finding this. Like anything that does that for you? Yeah. I mean, I really like
authorization bypass, um, a lot. Um, it's my, it's like one of my favorites, uh, just to, I don't know if,
if it's the smirkiness of just having bypass logins, you know, like, I don't know like what
that is, but yeah. Um, which usually comes through like, you know, different methods of content
discovery, which, you know, a lot of people are like, Oh, that's not hacking. But I mean,
I, I sure as hell get access to accounts. So, you know, like whatever. Yeah. So that's great,
man. So authorization, authorization, bypass or authentication bypass. Um, you know, what is
your, in just, you know, uh, we don't have to get, get too much into the weeds, but if you could just
give us a little bit of a brief methodology for, for finding those that you kind of want to share.
And, uh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, um, I mean, so identifying how applications, uh,
I talked about this in my last talk, but how applications reference users in an application
is really important, right? Whether it's a UUID or it's completely based on the session token
and every request that you pass, but like invariably applications will, you know,
add more functionality onto the app, which, you know, sometimes they'll even create edge cases where
they introduce the, you know, UUID or something like that. And is it as simple as an email address
that's representing a user? Or is it, you know, like a randomized token or how random is the token?
Um, and so for authorization and authentication, I will,
well, first I want to identify like, what is it that's making me me? Right. Um, and then I want
to identify if there's multiple user levels in the account that, um, that, you know, have more power
than me to do cool stuff that I can't do. Right. So many applications have this nowadays. Um, and so
there's plenty of videos out there now, but I mean, until very recently there wasn't, and, you know,
using authorize or auth matrix or two tools inside of burp that I used to do manually. And I still
honestly probably do more manually than I use the burp plugins, but I just create, I create an Excel
table, which I know is so ghetto, but I create an Excel table of everything I can do. And every one of
those dynamic functions in one account, um, and, uh, that I can do, and then I log out and then I create
another account, um, or I just create another browser instance. And I try to access the other
users, um, session, uh, or, you know, uh, basically areas. Um, I, uh, I try to substitute numerical
IDs. If I've referenced, it's a numerical UUID. Um, I try to do all kinds of trickery and I spend about,
you know, two hours probably doing that stuff between accounts. And then if I can get access to an
administrator account, um, I try to make sure that both an unauth user and a regular user can't access
the administrative function via just post requests and, you know, whatever else API calls or whatever.
And so really on the website and kind of the configuration panels and most app functions,
it's very, it's getting better these days that these bugs don't exist, um, as much as they used to,
they used to be all over the place. I used to find them all the time, but now they've shifted to
the API world where there's multiple user levels in the API world. Now it's just kind of shifted over
the API and API developers are a new breed of, you know, younger developers who, you know,
unless they have a framework that's strictly telling them how to segregate user roles,
they don't. And it's, and you get wrecked by, you know, like, uh, by these types of bugs against APIs.
Um, so the other one I really liked though is, um, uh, and, and this one, um, I was really validated
when I went to go actually see Mark Litchfield doesn't hardly ever talk about his methodology,
except for when he used to have a site. Um, but I went to a talk that he did at, um, Tinder,
um, where I talked next or after him and I was really validated because his whole talk was his
approach to finding authorization bypass against, um, big sites, man. What I wouldn't give to have
seen that. It was, it was amazing. Cause I was like, yes, I do this too. This is awesome. Um,
and so one of the stories I had was basically, um, this, this company that had a bug bounty scope.
Um, and, uh, what they needed was a CRM for their business, um, to, to integrate with their
platform. And so what they did is I found out via press releases, they bought another company,
they acquired a CRM company, a small one, but, uh, an up and coming small CRM company. Um,
and they purchased it for use, uh, on them. And so the website was still up for, um, the CRM software,
um, for the old company to run a demo. Um, and so like, you know, I had found the CRM instance
that the new company had stood up and, uh, and basically, um, you know, they had branded it
like they wanted to brand it changed its name, but it was still the same software. And all I had access
to was a login portal, which I had no credentials to. Um, and so what I, you know, what I did and,
you know, you should add this to your methodology. I think it happened with my talks is,
is I found the core software and you can do this if it's open source code. Um, but you can also do it
if it's not open source code, but they still have a demo portal available for the old site.
And so I went to the old developers website. I logged into their demo portal, which they gave
away for free, um, to, you know, test the CRM and I just mapped it in burp. And then I exported all
those URLs to a file and just replaced the domain, um, for, uh, for the new company, um, without any
authentication. And I started replaying the requests or the URLs and the endpoints against the new thing.
And I found a couple of paths where they had forgot to lock down, uh, permissions.
Um, one of them, um, was this function in this app in the CRM that managed, um, text message or SMS
based message, uh, to their users. Um, and so, uh, basically I had access to this control panel that
had their API key for this text message service. And I could send text messages to over, I think there
was 4 million clients already in the CRM. Yeah. Um, so I had that API key and I could do that, um,
by just taking the API key and then using it directly with the service through like a, you know, like a
curl request. Um, and then, so I, I kept looking, um, and I found some other places where it wasn't
locked down. Um, and I'm trying to remember, uh, so I submitted that as a bug. That was a big one.
Um, and then I found, uh, I found a verbatim API that they had set up and, um, I had some predefined
passing the eight for the API, which was a user access. Uh, it was an API call to basically deliver
your, your profile settings. Um, but you know, like many APIs do, they'll give you back everything,
but, uh, it had a user variable in the, in the URL and it was like, it was a numeric variable and they
just hadn't made it unique at all. It was like, it was like six characters or something like that.
And so I brute force that path. Uh, and I had the one from the old website. So I knew it was six
characters. And so I brute force that path to seven characters, I think in burp. Um, and I hit,
eventually I hit one of the admins of the applications, uh, profile setting, uh, API endpoint,
and that returned his, uh, his password, a verbatim password. Um, and so then I logged in,
I logged into the application on their side and I had access to this CRM was crazy. Like the amount
of information it had, like was nuts. This company is huge. They're worldwide, like worldwide brand.
Um, and so, I mean, and then I just wrote up the most amazing finding you can think of. I'm like,
with this access, I can basically do anything. I was like, I'll push text messages and JavaScript
into your app to take over all their users' phones. Like, yeah, I made a little proof. I was like,
so this customer is notorious for like, prove the impact. And I was like, I am writing a report
that absolutely shows what I could do as a malicious person here. Just so you know,
there is impact. Yeah, yeah, exactly. There is not any lack of impact. Yeah, exactly. So the trick
there is, is like, basically, you know, when you're testing and you're testing against a, uh, COTS,
I call it common off-the-shelf software, whether it's open source or it's had a demo at some point,
dump, install it yourself. Yeah, awesome acronyms. Oh, thanks. Yeah. Uh, yeah. COTS is actually an
industry one. So yeah, COTS software. Yeah. So, you know, whether you purchase it or whether it's open
source or whether it was closed sourced as a SaaS, try to get access to the software, install it yourself,
dump all of the end points and parameters that you can from your install or from the live running demo
or whatever, and then replay those against the site. And I have hit that so many times against,
uh, bug bounties for authorization issues. Dude, it's crazy. Like, it's so funny you mentioned
this because we're, we're all in this, you know, hacker one world's cup thing. Yeah. And I've got
a guy right now that I'm working with on our team that, uh, he's like, oh, this host is kind of
interesting. Right. And I look at it and I literally did that exact same thing. Like I went
to the, the website, there was a demo portal. You could log in with, with default credentials.
You know, you get in there, you figure out how the app is structured. You pull all the routes,
you try to hit those routes on the actual website and dude, that's such a gold technique. Yeah. It's
landed me so many bugs. And then, you know, what we did is, is there's also, you know, you can buy
the software for pretty cheap. Yeah. So we just, you know, paid the money, you know, got the software
and, and pull it down and just start reading through getting access to source code. And when
you've got access to source code, the game gets so much easier. Oh yeah, for sure. You can start,
you know, even if you're just grabbing off of keywords or anything like that, you know, it's,
it's a big, big difference. So big, big second to that tip. That's a great one, Jason.
So the, the followup on that is that, um, so this is one, not a lot of people know,
and I'll let it go on the podcast. So is that many of those paid software that you don't want to pay for that
are, that are made by big companies? Like maybe that, you know, rhyme with a borical or something
like that. I don't know. Um, the most boring company out there. Yeah. Uh, many developers
develop their environments in Docker, and then they upload a Docker file of the installed software
to Docker hub or another service like Docker hub. And you can pull down and I popped the bug.
Oh, okay. Okay. Sorry. I'm, I'm releasing your guys' secrets here, but, uh, so you download that
Docker hub and you host it yourself and now you have access to source code review, which gives you a
heads up against many, many, many, many things. Oh yeah. Yeah. And, and I talked about this at my,
my DEF CON talk this past year as well. It's like, you know, I, it was, it was, um,
Sam herb that I was working on a program with, and he did this exact same thing, went down,
pulled the Docker down, you know, you didn't even have to pay for the software because the
Dockerized version, you know, it requires you to put in a license key or whatever, but you can just pop
in there and grab all the, you know, source code and stuff like that. So that's a big, that's a big one.
Um, a big win for sure that, that people should be on the lookout for. Yeah. Uh, so I, I had one
other one that was more just fun than really technical, but, um, I pulled it cause a lot of
mine, I like a lot of my best hacks I post on Twitter as threads. Um, and I, I obviously obfuscate
all the names and everything like that, but I think they're fun to read for people. And so some of my
good ones I've already had, I wanted to bring you guys that weren't on the web yet that eventually
I will turn into threads, but they're not there yet. So this one, um, was a major auto
manufacturer. That's what I will say. Um, and, uh, it wasn't in the last big batch of Sam's research
with, um, with the Homsack and Zayat and everybody, but, um, but, uh, it was in kind of a previous
generation of, of car hacking. Um, and so this one was actually recon based. So I had started, uh,
basically looking at the site and one of the things I like to do is I call it, um, what the hell do I
call it? I put it in one of my talks, but it's, it's like, it's like a recursive recon or whatever.
Basically you load up your site and burp and you set up a keyword in your site, uh, in your scope
settings that says to allow scope with the keyword in it of the company. So not a domain. So not like,
you know, uh, you know, not a Tesla.com, but just the word Tesla, right? You want to see everything.
How I do my, my scope setup. Okay, cool. Very cool. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Like company
word or like key phrase. Yep. Exactly. Yep. So that's what I do. And then I recursively spider all
those sites. So I'll spider everything that comes up in me browsing the site and then I'll select
everything and spider it again. And then I'll just do it until there's no more sites basically that are
cross-linked between everything. And so it gives me a pretty good feel of everything that has that keyword in
it. And so I ended up getting all of these weird top level or, you know, domains, not sub domains,
but domains that I have never seen before that have the keyword in them. And I'm like, oh, that's
pretty cool. So I was doing this for a big auto manufacturer and I found this domain that was like
random four letter words. I'm sure they're abbreviation for something and then the keyword.
And I'm like, that domain seems interesting. So I go looking at that domain and it's basically
just a blank white page. Right. And like, I'm like, okay, that's weird. Like whatever.
So I started doing content discovery on this blank white page. Right. Which is kind of what I do
because there's nothing else to do there. Right. Like there's no content. Right. So it's like, whatever.
So I started doing content discovery and I start getting hits back for, um, for paths for Jenkins
and, um, and for some other, you know, CICD tools. And I'm like, oh, okay, cool. So I start loading up
my browser. And so the story behind this is it's not that fancy. Right. I did content discovery.
I basically walked into an unsecured Jenkins install. Um, I basically walked into what else they had
Sona type Nexus running up there. Um, it was all good. Yeah. All source code. Yeah. All source
code for the organization, like all of their infotainment source code. Uh, it was nuts, but, uh,
the story is that I found out from a person that works there after I submitted the bug bounty thing.
And she's like, he's like, I gotta tell you the story about this thing. And I'm like, okay.
And he's like, we have been telling our developer staff that they can't move to modern CICD tools for
longest time. Cause we're in waterfall and like, we're an old car company and like, we're just not
going to, you know, move yet. We are eventually, but we're not yet. The development team by themselves
purchased a domain and started using the CICD tools that they wanted without telling the organization.
So the org had no idea. This whole domain was public to the internet and it had all of the,
the source code in it and like, and they had just gone rogue basically because the org wouldn't let
them get fired. Yeah. Right. And so, you know, like I, I mean, I had, I, again, I wrote up like a
pretty exhaustive finding. I had so many hard coded credentials in the source. I had, I had like access
to everything I could show the, I could show the domain or the server that Jenkins was on because
it had the script console thing where you can run jobs and that's a common red team or tactic. And
yeah. Um, but yeah, I mean, there's like four different source code tools on there. So, uh,
I think it was Sonatype Nexus, uh, Jenkins, uh, team forge was on there. Um, and some other stuff too.
And, uh, yeah, but I just thought it was super funny that like the dev team had just gone rogue
and started using all these tools. Like a security team's nightmare. Yeah. No, it's absolutely
security team's nightmare. Yeah. But I thought that was a funny one. And it's crazy. You know,
that we see that sort of stuff from time to time too. Like that, that absolutely does happen. And,
and, uh, it's a different world, you know, world and the security world. So sometimes when you're
dealing with the bureaucracy, you know, who knows someone might just go around it.
Yeah. The, uh, the other one that's similar to that is, is, uh, I was on a bounty and I found a
red team infrastructure for, um, their go fish instance. And so I found it on the internet and I was
doing recon and I'm like, what is this domain that looks kind of like the other domains,
but is coming up. And they had, what did they, they had cross linked it somewhere that I had hit
on it and it showed up and burped. And like, I was like, weird. And then I go to it and it's like
a go fish install and default. Like I had a pretty default credential, like admin, admin or something
like that. And I log into their go fish instance. And I'm like, is this a finding? Like if I found
your red team's like go fish instance, it was, it was super funny. And my friend works on that red team
and he's like, bro, you just burnt our domain. And I'm like, Oh no, what are you doing man?
Yeah. That's dirty, bro. You can't, you can't do that. I know. I feel that all the time though,
man. Like I, I, you know, well, I won't share too much details, but you know, I, I have been
convicted in the past of like, uh, you know, I'm writing this code right now. This is shit code.
You know, I know it, but I'm going to write it anyway, but I know it. So like, that's the difference.
At least I'm acknowledging it. That's the difference between me and the devs is I know
I'm making a double mistake. Yeah. Yeah. And, uh, I think the last one was one
that I did do a thread on, but it was, um, the password manager that we hacked. So, um, so this was
back in my early, early pen test days and there were multiple players in the password kind of last
pass. Um, there was several, uh, back then that were trying to win the space. And so, uh, basically,
um, we were on this call and at that time it was my salesperson, Deanna, who was the nicest person in
the world. Um, she, she set up this call with this company. They contacted us actually, and they were
abusive to her on the phone. Like basically like just jerks. They're like, you know,
like, I don't even know why we're talking to your company. We wouldn't have to do this unless we were
compliance. We're one of the best dev teams in the world. Like, um, your team's not going to find
anything. Like they gave her a hassle about like pricing and communication, you know, cadence. And
she was awesome. She was like the coolest person at the company, honestly. Um, and so she came to us,
the engineering team of, you know, you, normally this, the project is only supposed to be applied to
one of us for a web tease. Right. And she's like, she's like, can you guys wreck this company?
And I was, and we were like, yeah. And we were like, we were like, yes, Deanna,
we will do that for you. And so it was, yeah. And, and you know, maybe it was a tactic of theirs
to try to piss off us to get better testing, but they got good testing. So, um, so I spent a,
I had spent a week, um, doing recon and I was getting like, not recon, but like, um, you know,
basically application profiling and I hadn't really found too much yet. Um, they managed their password
manager via a bookmarklet and, um, or an extension. And it was pretty much the same. They had a public
facing website, um, you know, with standard functionality, uh, that would, that would log
you into like your vault that would pull things from, you know, that would interact with the extension.
And, um, so like, this is very early on in my web testing. So I did content discovery with back then
it was, um, Dyrbuster. Um, and so I had found a whole bunch of paths that were giving me 403s
and other error codes that were not standard. One of them was like Gmail, PHP. One of them was,
um, one of them was PHP, my admin, but they were locked down, right? I couldn't get to them.
Um, and, uh, keywords that are really taking me back. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Right. It's old.
This one's old. Yeah. Here we go. Yeah. Actually PHP, my admin was not locked down. It just was a login
screen though. And I didn't have credentials for it. And so, um, what, what we ended up doing is the,
the fuzzing methodology that I've been doing for years, right. Is, is I just started fuzzing every
dynamic parameter. Um, and at one point I hit, uh, I hit a minifier, um, parameter and it started
giving weird error messages. And I found that out through the, the word count basically. Um,
and so I was like, this is weird. So I went to my buddy, Paul, who was much smarter than me at the
time in web testing. And I was like, Hey, we might want to look at this. And also we're, we're getting at
the end of our testing window and you know, like, let's, let's just dive into this. And he's like,
okay, so we're all doing different parts and we had all discovered like some paths, but nothing really
critical. And so by fuzzing this minify function, um, we were noticing that it was giving us error
codes that said like, like incorrect pathing or something like that. And we were like, that's
weird. It's referencing pathing. Maybe we can pop an LFI here. Um, and, but we couldn't get it.
So we spent three days playing with this error code. And, um, and then, you know, we did the
standard investigation. Okay. What are they coding the front end? And then it was like code igniter
basically. And we were like, okay, so like, let's look through the code igniter documentation.
And we sound this, this small reference in the code igniter documentation. I think it was that
sometimes you can change the dots in a path reference to underscores to work better with the
web basically for some reason. And so we replaced the dots with underscores in our LFI path and we're
able to echo out files from the web server. Yep. Yep. So then, so then we, you know, we go through every
page that we had found echo at the source code for all the pages.
Um, the web route was pretty standard. So we started going in now. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, um, and then, um,
eventually we go to that, the content discovery we had done and we start echoing out those pages that we had
found via the content. So gmail.php echoed out an integration script for the, the main developer of the
site that had his personal Gmail credentials in the, in, in the integration script. And so then we log into his
personal Gmail of which he has source code in his, um, in his, uh, his Google drive, basically in his Google
drive. And so we're like messing around in there. Um, and then, uh, we were able to, uh, we were able to
eventually get a credential from his Google drive that logged us into PHP, my admin. Uh, and then, uh,
we got into PHP, my admin. We added our own super user accounts, uh, injecting a hash directly into the
database, uh, through PHP, my admin. Um, and then, uh, what else did we do?
Dude, I love this so much. Yeah. This is just like, this is like what red team dreams are made.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um, yeah, it was, uh, and I mean, we did some other stuff too. Like eventually
we backdoored to the plugin, a version of the plugin, not the production live one, but we said,
here's what we could have done. We could have backdoored the plugin and, or the extension and pulled
everybody's passwords as they were making them. Uh, we found code, we found cross site scripting
once we had access to circuit. Oh, that's what we did. So once we had the LFI, not only did we pull
down the pages we knew existed for the website, but we went through, we installed, like I said,
this is part of the methodology. We installed code igniter, code igniter base install on one of our
servers, and then took out all the paths and files that we saw from that as a list, and then ran it through
the LFI. And through that, we got API keys that they had hard coded in source code. And like, uh,
we had so much information and it was, it was great. We had completely owned them by the end. And we went
on this call on the, on the like kickoff call and they were like so confident that we weren't going to
find anything. And so we start going through the report, how we had just wrecked them. And they were like,
like, they were just dumbfounded. Yeah. Yeah. We have screenshots. Yeah. Yeah. We have screenshots
of the dude's personal email. People are G chatting him. And we're just like, we're like,
yeah, this is us like in your, your email. And, um, yeah, so that was, that was one of the more
satisfying ones of my career. And it took a village. It took all four of us, you know, at the end, but,
uh, it was so fun. You really defended your, your salesperson there. Yeah. That's awesome.
Yeah. Dude, that's, that's awesome to hear. And, and I don't know, I, when I was in, when I was in
consulting, I definitely liked working with the people that were more like, all right, let's like
work together on this. Yeah, exactly. Value out of this. Yeah. But there is definitely those moments
where the people are like, yeah, you know, if you find anything, let us know. Yeah. Yeah.
All right. Yeah. Yeah. It's like a hacker challenge. You're like, let's go. All right. Yeah.
Yeah. That's great, man. Yeah. We are at Joel. We're at an hour 45 minutes.
Oh, I'm sorry. I'm so sorry, guys. No, Jason. No, no, this is awesome.
Yeah. It's phenomenal content. Wouldn't trade it for the world. Um, let's wrap it up though. Jason,
is there any, you already shouted out, but, oh, but, um, you know, quite extensively. Yeah.
Yeah. Product there, but anything else you want us to, you know, you want to shout out here at the end?
Uh, no, I just, I'm super glad you guys are doing this podcast. I think that we need more, uh,
like bug bounty type stuff, you know, I don't know. I think bug bounty hunters are no different than any
other security testers, right? So I actually don't think of this as a bug bounty podcast. I think of you guys as
like an app sec or a testing podcast, right? And so we just need more of it out there. People talking
about stuff, especially people who are familiar with new school development and cloud and stuff
like that. So I'm just really happy that I got a chance to come on, talk to you guys and really
appreciate it. And if you're out there and you're hacking, just keep hacking, you know, keep at it.
Yeah. Keep at it.
Awesome. For sure.
Yeah. Awesome. Awesome. Yeah. You can find, um, Jay, Jay Haddix on Twitter.
Yeah. Yeah. Jay had most places. Yeah. Yeah. Dude, this was an awesome conversation. Thanks so much.
No, no problem. Thanks guys. Awesome. Awesome. That's the pod.
Sweet. See ya. Cool.